ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman welcome to the show hope
everybody had a good weekend i will talk
a little bit about mine uh on the bonus
show today some interesting things that
went on
the vaccine chaos is growing
dramatically and we are already starting
to see
new talking points develop from people
who simply don't want to talk about
whether they are vaccinated
i will preview that the term hipaa plays
a prominent role
in those talking points we also have an
nfl assistant coach
who is out after refusing a coveted
vaccine
and the nfl clearly getting very very
serious about vaccination
rick dennison is out as the minnesota
vikings assistant coach after refusing a
covid 19 vaccine
after refusing to receive a vaccine for
covet 19 rick dennison
is out as the minnesota vikings
assistant coach sources told espn
dennison had served as the vikings
offensive line coach run game
coordinator the past two seasons
in a statement friday the vikings said
they were still in discussions with
denison about the league's coveted
protocols
another coach in the league new england
new england patriots co-offensive line
coach cole popovich
also won't be with his team in 2021 in a
decision related
to the covid19 vaccine and nfl
guidelines league sources confirmed to
espn
the vaccine is required for all tier one
staff including coaches front office
executives equipment managers and scouts
players are not required to receive the
vaccine but will face strict protocols
during training camp and throughout the
season
that vaccinated players can forego i
will get to that in a moment
in a memo released by the league this
summer the nfl said any unvaccinated
tier 1 staff member
must provide a valid religious or
medical reason for not receiving the
vaccine
losing tier 1 status prohibits coaches
from being on the field
and in meeting rooms and having direct
interactions with
players the vikings noted in their
statement that denison does not have a
vaccination exemption
the vikings have promoted someone in
order to fill that seat
so on and so forth so a few different
things
uh to think about here first and
foremost
is this guy dennison going to eventually
be a republican congress
candidate for congress is he going to
appear on fox news as a hero
but even if he appears on fox news it
would have to be via skype why well even
though fox hosts talk a lot about
vaccine requirements and vaccine
passports
fox requires that if you don't want to
wear a mask
in their facilities that you have to be
wearing a
you have to be wearing a mask so i guess
this guy
could be hailed as a hero on fox news
but would have to do the interview via
skype because he's not vaccinated so
that hypocrisy is just incredible
now as i tweeted about this when the
news broke the team
as a private business made a decision
about how they wanted to employ people
without breaking any law
the coach made a decision about where he
would or would not like to work
this is in effect the libertarian
paradise this is happening by the way
around the same time that the nfl has
had to
postpone games because of coronavirus
outbreaks among unvaccinated players or
staffers
and that those are not going to be
rescheduled if indeed that would have
i think i was not clear they announced
that they will not be rescheduling games
that happen as a result
of that are postponed as a result of
unvaccinated people if people are
unvaccinated
and there's an outbreak that's going to
just be a forfeit
and the nfl getting very very strict
about this stuff they also
announced that they are going to be
fining unvaccinated players fourteen
thousand dollars
if they violate covet protocols and the
new protocols are quite
quite interesting the nfl having one
list of protocols if you're fully
vaccinated
and another if you're not so for example
if you're fully vaccinated you don't
need to be tested daily
if you're not vaccinated you will need
to be tested every single day
if you're fully vaccinated you don't
need to wear a mask when you are at the
team's facility or during travel
if you choose not to be vaccinated you
will be required
to wear a mask all season presumably at
club facilities and during travel
other examples there will be no physical
distancing required
if you are with other vaccinated
individuals and are vaccinated yourself
versus if you are not fully vaccinated
you have to remain physically distant
presumably for the entire season so i
don't know
about you but if i was a player i would
be wanting to be fully vaccinated in
order not to have to do
any of that stuff and there are already
people who are typically
on the oh the nfl is so fantastic and
it's patriotic and all of this stuff who
are saying
screw football if they want to go woke
by the way following the science is not
wokeness it's just following the science
if they want to go all whatever it is
that the right claims they are going
then i'm not going to watch the nfl is
the one that's coming up now and you
know what
that is all the marketplace of ideas the
nfl
broke no laws by putting these rules in
place
if they lose business or viewership or
whatever as a result
that was their choice to make if people
don't want to work for the nfl or for
any particular team because of the rules
they are free to go
and market their labor elsewhere and
if the audience doesn't want to watch
the nfl in protest of these rules
they are free to do that and then that
will have an impact and the nfl will
have to decide whether it's worth it or
not it seems to me
based on everything that's going on
including with the delta variant
etc that the nfl is simply being
cautious because they want to preserve
the integrity of their season and people
can disagree and then they can
vote with their eyeballs and choose to
watch something else
we have another one of these situations
where
an anti-vaccine pro-trump
individual in this case a radio host has
been hospitalized with kovid this is
phil valentine
he's really sick i hope he doesn't die
he is
really really sick and we will get to
that in a moment now
these stories are really starting to
almost in a sense get old
two weeks ago i told you about the
anti-vaccine nurse
who died in her 30s young
anti-vaccine nurse died of covet
last week i told you about the anti-vaxx
pro-trump
cape cod elected official um i
believe her name was linda zwern zern
something like that she died and then
now
we have a right-wing radio host
slate reporting conservative radio host
skeptical of vaccines hospitalized with
kovid
quote he's regretful
this is phil valentine a conservative
radio host in
tennessee who was openly skeptical about
covid vaccines
has been hospitalized and is now in
critical care with the disease phil
valentine who hosts a show on
nashville's wwtn
was diagnosed with the coronavirus and
is now quote in very serious condition
as he battles
pneumonia his family said in a statement
posted
to the radio station's twitter account
although he needs help
breathing valentine is not on a
ventilator as of a few days ago the
latest report is he is not getting
better
while making it clear that the
experience has changed his stance
on vaccination a
statement was posted
by supertalk wtn this is
reportedly from his family
phil contracted the covet virus a little
over a week ago
and has since been hospitalized and is
in very serious condition
suffering from covered pneumonia and the
attendant side effects
he is in the hospital in the critical
care unit breathing
with assistance but is not on a
ventilator we'd ask that everyone
refrain from contacting him while he's
in the hospital
phil would like for his listeners to
know that while he has never been an
anti-vaxxer he regrets not being more
vehemently or vehemently pro-vaccine and
looks forward to being able to more
vigorously advocate that position as
soon as he's back on the air
which we hope will be soon phil and his
family would like for you all to know
that he loves y'all
and appreciates your concern thoughts
and prayers more than you will ever know
please continue to pray for his recovery
and please go get vaccinated of course
the prayers would not be necessary had
he been vaccinated
from the beginning this is a perfect
example of 2020
hindsight now i know there are people in
the audience who say screw this guy
i hope he recovers and i hope that he
spreads
the wisdom of vaccination i hope he
recovers
so we can find out if he's really
learned anything from this
but i am betting that the rest of his
right-wing paradigm on which the
anti-vac
stuff was based is going to remain
wholly intact now
one other thing i want to mention he
said
the family statement says he was never
anti-vaxxed but he was
not as for the vaccine as he should have
been this is a very common talking point
that's used
which is the coveted anti-vaxxers will
say i'm not anti-vaxx
in that i'm i'm fine with other vaccines
and i've received other vaccines
that doesn't really mean that much
because the other vaccines are ones
that there is so much acceptance of in
society
that it really doesn't actually matter
whether this guy is for
or against the mmr because other than
some little anti-vax clusters that
eventually prop up
we've got very solid immunity against
measles bumps and rubella
it's it's really a red herring to say
i'm not anti-vaxx in that i'm okay with
the other vaccines
this is the one that i'm skeptical of
this is what's present right now this is
the the near and present danger at this
point in time
uh let's i'm hoping for his recovery
because i don't want anybody to die
that's my view and i know some in the
audience feel differently
we just have a disagreement what we
can't possibly disagree about
is that monday august 16th marks
the 16th anniversary of the david pakman
show
wow can you imagine that and we will be
doing a one-day membership special in
commemoration of that
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and monday august 16th you'll get an
email telling you
how to avail yourself of that amazing
membership discount
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use to get
my head in the game and prepare myself
for the interview because ground news is
a news source comparison platform that
lets you
compare how outlets from the left right
and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted argument
for debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground
news app today by going to ground.news
pacman i would love it quite frankly i
mean i'm not going to hide it i would
love it if you
grabbed a membership on my website it is
the primary funding source for our
program we are an independent
progressive media show we have no
money tree in the backyard i've got an
eggplant back there
quite an eggplant uh in fact i posted my
eggplant plant to my instagram over the
weekend but
no money tree still looking on a uh low
chill variety of that
but uh no in all seriousness um i would
love it if you signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com we do an extra show
every day for our paid subscribers
and it really makes it so that when
youtube revenue goes up down or
disappears or facebook revenue goes up
down or disappears
the membership uh revenue keeps us
closer to stable
and many of you know that and you can
use the coupon code better21
to get a membership at joinedpakman.com
all right we are going to do a deep dive
into the bowels of the republican party
and we are going to see that through the
lens of a completely deranged and
demented speech given by the former
president donald trump
in phoenix arizona over the weekend the
context of this speech
was that it was one of these turning
point usa that's that college republican
group
it was a turning point usa event in
phoenix in support
of the election audits or ardits as some
call them which
some republicans still believe are
imminently going to
lead to the reinstatement of donald
trump now none of that is going to
happen
it's hard to even call the audit an
audit but
we learned so much from this speech
about the
state of the average republican voter
so let's get right into it first of all
just the introduction for donald trump
is beyond parody satire is dead
trump coming out to dubstep mixed in
with that lame
country song that we're supposed to
pretend that a rich guy from queens
actually likes take a look at this
ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the 45th president of the
united states of america
donald j trump
[Music]
okay so you get it completely beyond
parody unable to be satired uh putting
saturday night live completely out of
business
but the content the content was a mix of
lies yes delusions
of course and also just completely
unintelligible statements in this clip
trump refers to the authors of the audit
i assume he means the auditors
he also instead of talking about
affidavits
he seems to say affidavit it's all weird
we can't let this happen yet this is
only the beginning of the irregularities
the arizona
audit is uncovering the authors and the
auditors have collected
a sworn affidavit stating
so the auditors have uncovered the
authors
and the authors found affidatus
so you know that seems to be listen if
you want
a predictor as to whether these audits
will have an
impact the fact that trump says that
they are authors finding
affidatus it's all not good it's all not
good and then maybe in the most bizarre
moment of the entire speech
donald trump repeating the word routers
more than 10 times in 36 seconds
i challenge you to prove that trump even
knows what a router is
the county has for whatever reason also
refused to produce the network routers
we want the routers sunny
wendy we got to get those routers please
the routers come on kelly we can get
those
routers those routers you know what
we're so beyond the routers there's so
many fraudulent votes without are we
because you don't sound like you're
beyond them
but if you got those routers what that
will show
and they don't want to give up the
routers they don't want to give them
they are fighting like hell why are
these commissioners fighting
not to give the routers how simple could
it be
that will tell the truth so that's very
strange
something really weird going on there
almost like trump falling into some kind
of
linguistic black hole where he just
can't keep they can't stop repeating the
same word
and then we go from confusion to just
lies
trump says that the real big lie
is that joe biden won in other words the
lie
being told is biden won the truth as
trump
sees it is he actually was the winner
in november now nine months ago the big
lie they call it you know what's the big
lie
the opposite is the big lie election was
the big lie
and i've got to tell you i i've got to
say this i've never said it before but
i've always
thought it uh oh if i lost the election
i'm okay with that i'm okay with it
seriously
if we lost the election we'll lose an
election
i'll go home i'll start building
buildings i'll do something i'll keep
myself busy
now this is funny because he did lose
and he promised before
if i lose you won't see me again and yet
here he is in like speech number five or
six
since losing the election but he just
continued his argument is i didn't
actually lose but you know what
if we lost the election we know when we
lose you don't
yeah so there's there's that um and then
uh trump just continuing to with this
stuff let's look at one more of these
if i lost this election i could handle
it pretty easily
when they steal it from you and rig it
that's not easy and we have to fight we
have no choice
so there it is that's what i alluded to
before which is trump just doesn't
believe that he lost he says
if i lost i would accept losing and i
would be fine i would be a big boy i
would be an adult
well but sir this time sir sure
you're not actually acting like an adult
but you said you would well no it's
because i didn't actually lose oh okay
okay i mean just completely disconnected
and the crowd cheering is a real sign to
us
the fact that these crowds continue to
believe this tells us a lot about the
state
of the republican electorate at this
point in time then
trump again sort of alludes to the idea
that
once these audits are done he'll be back
in office
and of course there's no mechanism for
such reinstatement and of course the
audits aren't real audits
and of course he didn't actually win and
you know i don't think i need to tell
you
they almost got away with it they may
have gotten away with it we're going to
find out because something's going to
have to be done
something i don't think so something i
don't think so
you know if somebody robs tiffany
a beautiful jeweler 57th and 5th good
location
excellent location and they steal the
diamonds
and then they get caught they have to
turn the diamonds back the diamonds it's
very simple
amazing the way it works
so apparently returning stolen jewelry
to tiffany's at 57th
and 5th is equivalent to the
reinstatement of a president
nine months post an election uh
it's all very very strange and you and i
might say david who could possibly
believe that at this point
the people in the crowd at least some of
them seem to believe it check out what
donald trump then claimed about the
first
six months of joe biden's presidency but
you know what
if instead of doing the horrible they're
saying it was the worst six months
in the history of the presidency i don't
know that that's true but i would say it
is
but you know it's not true trump's
instinct there i don't know if it's true
what what's what's amazing to me about
that is all the people saying we've gone
down a communist
spiral and it's all dystopian and it's
all terrible
socialist marxists etc imagine
being so disconnected from reality that
you believe
biden has even done that much one way or
the other i mean quite frankly
many people myself included wish that
joe biden
had done more now there might be people
who would disagree with the stuff biden
did if he did it and people who would
agree but he's just not done that much
he did some executive orders right up
front to reverse some of the most
atrocious things that donald trump did
he got coveted stimulus passed which was
a great thing but it's relatively low
hanging fruit globally
europe looks at the controversy that
took place here over
biden's covet stimulus package which
republicans were against despite signing
off right away on the trump stimulus
packages which were very very similar
he he hasn't even done that much one way
or the other and the idea that in six
months
so much has happened aside from whether
you like it
that this would be the most significant
anything six months of a presidency
it's just imaginary and then trump
starts leaning more heavily on the
communist stuff
like it or not we are becoming a
communist country that's what's
happening
i continue to recommend that when people
say that
say what does communist mean what can
you define communism what exactly is a
communist society an economy a
government
it's a really fun experiment because it
goes nowhere and then
donald trump recommending the vaccine
but also recommending freedom
we are at the beginning of a communist
system
radicals are seizing power and
destroying
everything we hold dear as americans
okay so that's more on the
communism stuff then trump recommends
the vaccine but also recommends freedom
it's like what does that mean
i mean how about the vaccine i came up
with the vaccine
they said it would take three to five
years gonna save the world
i recommend you take it but i also
believe in your freedoms a hundred
percent
but just so you understand but it was a
great achievement
and notice the crowd is not cheering for
i recommend the vaccine
the crowd is cheering for i recommend
freedom and that's
you know i recommend you take it but i
also recommend freedom yeah
and the delusional nature of i came up
with the vaccine
i mean aside from the fact that you know
it's scientists and
and people in medicine who come up with
the vaccine
the idea that trump did anything other
than just pre-purchase some vaccines
is laughable at this point it's crazy
that he's even still repeating that
and then trump finally gets to the topic
of running in 2024
and he says you know when when i talk
about people tell me running in 2024
i just won an election why do i need to
run again
you're way ahead of everybody running 24
sir
you're gonna win and i say wait a minute
i just won
six months ago
congratulations sir you just won the
election yeah
so trump uh insisting run again i just
won
this thing as many of you know the
election the olympics are going on
and then donald trump started sort of
goading the audience
into booing the u.s women's soccer team
which doesn't sound
particularly patriotic to me
demented the u.s women's soccer team is
a very good example of what's going
on
what earlier this week they unexpectedly
lost to sweden three to nothing
people are cheering the loss of the u.s
women so
i thought this was all about team
america the the the odd
they're cheering that the u.s women's
soccer team lost americans were happy
about it
no your crowd is happy about it dude
they're cheering
you proved that point before i even said
it
demented okay anyway so so trump almost
seeing
people cheering it as a good thing i
mean what what is considered patriotic
about that i thought this would these
were the people who had the monopoly on
patriotism
then in a bizarrely xenophobic moment
trump can't remember the name of a
taliban leader
and he just refers to him as muhammad
it's very strange it's a much different
deal
i told the taliban i spoke to the leader
and i spoke i said let's call him
muhammad i said muhammad
we're leaving yeah so his name is
actually heba tula akunzada but trump
absent remembering he's like well it's a
muslim guy
let's just call him muhammad bizarre
moment and of course like the implicit
xenophobia of that
going completely over the crowd's head
or not going over their head but they
like it
and then and this is really relevant to
what's going on within the party
when the name mike pence has mentioned
the crowd booze this is a republican
crowd
and i only wish that my friend mike
pence had that additional courage
send to send the results
back to the legislatures because
it all happened so quickly you know they
schemed in this plan for four years this
all happened
so the crowd not liking the former
republican president this is a
republican crowd by the way
and then lastly it all coming full
circle
trump describing a propaganda technique
that he's actually using to convince
people of stuff
but that's what they do and you know
what it's called disinformation
they make up a lot of crap and they say
it over
and over and over and
one day you say oh who was the one that
wanted to defund i guess it was the
republicans the republicans are against
a very
serious so anyway trump's saying
disinformation you repeat something
often enough and people start to believe
it which of course is what he has done
it's it's been his strategy i won i won
i won massive
vote dumb so all this different stuff uh
that's the technique that he uses he's
identifying a known technique
it's just he's attributing it to the
other side so what are the takeaways
here first of all
completely outrageous globally
humiliating speech i mean the fact that
a former president speaks this way is
doing these speeches is saying these
things is absolutely humiliating
and in addition to that in addition to
that is the reality
that he still mostly owns the republican
party the crowd is with him
although you have a hand you know liz
cheney who is only with trump
90 of the time says the the election
stuff has to stop
adam kinzinger who's going to be on the
house january 6th commission that starts
tomorrow
he's willing to say trump is wrong on a
couple of
but he mostly owns the republican party
and so the question is what happens in
22 with that
and what happens in 24 and i want to
hear from you
we'll have more coverage of this
deranged and demented speech on our
instagram at davidpakmanshow
you can leave your comments there or
wherever else you're watching or
listening today
let me know your thoughts
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive of
every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
all right we're going to go through two
confrontations that took place over the
last few days they are very different in
nature i think there's there are some
important things to be said about both
um rand paul was confronted by a
kentucky
resident during a town hall that he did
we're going to look at that a little bit
later but first i want to talk about
what happened to fox news propagandist
tucker carlson when he was at a
fishing store fish supply tackle bait
type store
you can tell i don't fish um in the
state of montana where he was confronted
and what i wanna
we're gonna look at the video we're
gonna look at the reporting but what i
really wanna focus in on here are two
things
one the reactions about the nature of
what took place here
from a speech standpoint that's number
one
and then number two the utter disgusting
dripping hypocrisy that comes uh with
this tactic which i've also i mean you
guys might remember i recently was also
confronted by someone who disagreed with
my political views
in public so let's get right into it
huffington post report man confronts
tucker carlson
at montana store you were the worst
human being when a local fly fishing
guide
spotted noted vaccine skeptic tucker
carlson at a sporting goods store in
livingston montana he did not waste time
dan bailey can be heard telling the fox
news host in a video you were the worst
human being known to mankind
he captioned the video it's not every
day you get to tell someone they are the
worst
person in the world and really mean it
what an
a-hole um there's one other interesting
aspect to this
which uh which i will get back to okay
so here's the video
if you're watching it's subtitled it's
only about 25 seconds long
i don't care man okay just dude you are
the worst human being
known to me i want you to put down
[Music]
settle down son is very very
condescending and
tucker is an expert clearly in being
condescending
probably picked up those techniques at
his various country clubs
um from reports about how he treats the
staff at country clubs a little bit more
here
all right so tucker then walking away
and looking apparently at some
flies or bait or something like that now
here's one up before we get into this
here here's the most incredible part of
this entire story
the guy who confronts tucker carlson is
named dan
bailey the confrontation happened at dan
bailey's fly shop
but the dan bailey who did the
confrontation
has nothing to do with dan
bailey's fly shop it's a coincidence
that a guy named dan bailey in
livingston montana
is in dan bailey's shop and is not
actually the dan bailey from the shop
like it
is this a common name or something it's
an incredible detail that just adds to
the entire insanity of it but okay so
what are the reactions i mean this was
speech right guys there was no physical
violence
if anything it was actually uh
tucker carlson who at different points
in time
is sort of getting very very close to
dan bailey
and and getting up really close to him
if you could argue if anybody was
physically intimidatory here uh it was
really more
tucker than anybody else so clearly
right wingers are in favor of the speech
right well not exactly
check out what dinesh d'souza said big
free speech advocate quote this is a
shocking video
this man should be arrested for what he
did
to tucker carlson in front of his
daughter first of all the moralizing
about in front of his daughter
i don't even know that i get that but
certainly it has no criminal relevance
but what would you arrest dan bailey for
that he expressed a view
that is different than that of dinesh
d'souza or different than that of tucker
carlson
or different than that of tucker
carlson's daughter maybe i mean who
knows what tucker carlson's daughter's
political views are
you are all about free speech and not
regulating and
all this different stuff and you want
someone arrested for something they said
when it was tucker who got real close to
the guy and actually started poking him
on the chest
what crime sir sir sure
yeah so this happened to me not that
long ago
okay i described the incident a little
while ago
um i was sitting outside at a terrace at
a restaurant
and as i was walking away i heard
someone go
hey pacman and i turned i was about 30
feet they watched me walk right by them
waited until i was 20 30 feet away then
said hey pacman i turn around
don't say anything just turn around and
they say
you jew imperialist bastard
change your ways and
as i've said before i'm not against the
principle
of the this technique um if you're a
public person and you're in public
people are going to come up and give you
their opinion and most of the time
people come up and they say hello and
they say they agree with my opinions it
just happened a few times this weekend
and every once in a while someone might
disagree this happened to be an ignorant
[ __ ] who was anti-semitic right
once they drop in you jew imperialist
bastard
but there's a different thing here it's
not
what i think about the technique what
does tucker himself think of the
technique well
tucker came out in favor of this
technique remember when tucker carlson
did an entire segment on his show urging
viewers
to accost mask wearing strangers
and parents of children who are being
told to wear a mask tucker said
accost them on the street he encouraged
it
and so he must be okay with this
technique right well
according to the daily beast reporter
justin baragona
a fox news spokesperson said that the
man in montana
was ambushing tucker carlson in a store
and that it was quote totally
inexcusable
and that no public figures should be
accosted regardless of political
persuasion or beliefs
due to the intolerance of another point
of view so wait a second guys
tucker's view is parents who are not
public figures
they're just parents if they are wearing
masks so their kids are wearing masks
even though they're not wanting to be
public people they're not choosing to be
public people they should be accosted
per tucker carlson but tucker as one of
the highest
rated uh hosts on fox news who
chooses to go out there and be a public
figure and say these things he's off
limit
that's the point of view between tucker
and fox news
it's deranged guys it is absolutely and
completely deranged
these people are hypocrites when you
know the principles first
people not only you know i've said
before principles first
is not always i mean okay talk about
principles but the difficulty is in
applying the principles to the real
world
and if you only talk about principles
you lose reality that's one critique of
principles first
the other critique is a lot of the
principles first people abandon their
principles as soon as it's inconvenient
to what they
what they actually want to experience in
real life so absolutely pathetic
and disgusting and um this this
is uh this has happened to me i've got
to deal with it i could stop doing my
show i could wear a disguise i could you
know do whatever the hell i want
um but uh the idea that this arrest
this man is just the you know it's it's
peak cringe
giga cringe i think is what i would uh
call it in fact
okay let's now move on to the next one
rand paul
rand paul did one of these town hall
virtual town halls recently
and a kentuckian named alexis tune
um she says she was contacted to
participate in the town hall
it's there's conflicting reports about
whether anybody could just call in or
whether she was
called to participate or whether she
asked to be called
but she told rand paul to get effed
during the town hall all right let's
take a look at the clip
and um you know to some degree i want to
mention that there is language that may
be
disturbing to some individuals and just
letting everybody know about that okay
here let's listen to rand paul
for that we'll go ahead to our next
question now
mrs alexis tune you are live with the
senator you can go ahead and ask your
question
hi senator i am a proud kentucky citizen
and i just wanted to tell you to get
oh man all right we'll go ahead
so a few um a few thoughts on this
there's not even a debate here this is
completely fine
now much like with the tucker carlson
confrontation where dinesh d'souza said
the man
who confronted tucker carlson should be
arrested which is just sort of like a
complete
and total joke um with this one
there is not even a debate as to whether
this is okay oh
foul language oh give me a break
uh i i have no problem with this
whatsoever
could you make the case that with the
opportunity that she was given alexis
tune could have made a substantive
confrontation of rand paul sure you
could say that
i don't know that it would have gotten
this level of attention
and uh you can just tell rand paul has
very much
practiced that complete and total
non-reaction his face not even moving
when when the bomb drops uh but i have
to tell you other than if you think
about the senate
maybe ted cruz deserves this more
maybe josh hawley deserves this more
it's hard to think of someone more
deserving than to be confronted for the
[ __ ] that he is
than rand paul that's the senate now if
you want to look at the house of
representatives there's a very long list
of people who deserve to be confronted
uh marjorie taylor greene matt gates
lauren bobert madison cawthorne kevin
mccarthy
jim jordan you know it's a very very
long list and
as childish as this is like in all
seriousness
elected officials should be less
isolated from just the thoughts of
random people
i am never advocating for physical
violence i'm not saying
throw eggs or milkshakes i'm not saying
anything anything like that at all
i'm talking about just words and really
having to
face the reality that what they are
doing
is not only disgusting to millions of
americans but it's also really bad for
the lives of millions of americans the
policies that they support
are terrible for millions and millions
of americans that's just a reality that
they should have to face
and um you know whether the extraneous
whether the out of school the after
school language so to speak
has to be a part of it no i'm not saying
that i don't really care about that
but being in less highly curated
moments where this can actually happen i
think
is a good thing for our elected
officials now some of you may say well
joe biden never does
that joe biden has had to deal with
peter ducey
one of the thief no peter yeah peter's
the kid
an extremely hostile reporter and he
regularly goes to him now
do i want joe biden talking more to
voters who disagreed with him yeah i
would like that
i think that that's just a great thing
and i try to take calls
when we do live calls from people who
disagree with me and
one of the things that i think is
important to remember
my view is even the people who call me
in complete bad faith
and want to sandbag me and they swear
and they insult or whatever
sometimes there's a kernel of truth to
the inconsistency that maybe they're
pointing out in a position that i've
taken
or whatever i find significant value of
that and if our elected officials were
more regularly exposed to that i think
it would be a very good thing
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david.pakman
i posted my second eggplant over the
weekend the picture went insta viral
more because of what was on my head than
the eggplant itself
take a look at it let me know what you
think
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show so the house
commission to investigate the january 6
trump riots is going to kick off
tomorrow now as you might remember this
is not the the
commission that was proposed uh months
ago which republicans rejected this is
the new one this is the one where
um kevin mccarthy the house minority
leader leader selected five republicans
and nancy pelosi said jim banks and jim
jordan can't be on
this committee they're sort of part of
the problem they should be maybe
witnesses
more than uh investigators and
ultimately
republicans saying well then we won't
give you anyone but nancy pelosi
inviting republican liz cheney
and republican adam kinzinger to
participate that kicks off tomorrow
and maybe we will get some more answers
to some of the questions that remain
about exactly what happened on january
6th although the big picture of what
happened is pretty clear
we knew at the time and it was reported
at the time donald trump seemed to
really like what was going on
until there was this moment on january 6
where donald trump was reportedly
watching and
the low-class nature as he saw it of his
protesters of the writers he felt was
making him look bad
that trump reportedly didn't like but
big picture trump seemed pretty pleased
with what was going on
we now have new reporting from this book
i alone can fix it by washington post
reporters uh
carol lenig and philip rucker where they
uh now are saying trump was quote almost
giddy
watching the capitol riot on tv
carol lennog co-author of i alone can
fix it described the scene
in an interview with cnn lennox said
trump was reluctant to call off the
rioters despite urging from daughter
ivanka that also relates to a story that
we recently covered
let's get right into the clip of carol
lenig
explaining it herself on cnn as the
attack on the capital is occurring
what is trump's state of mind what is
the feeling inside the white house
you know it's amazing because we
we all lived it we were in journalism
but we and america lived it through tv
and he is in his dining room off the way
off the oval office
watching it and almost giddy because i
mean he does watch a lot of tv
but here he is seeing thousands of his
supporters
basically trample up to the steps
breakthrough barricades
all rallying for him to try to stop the
certification of the election for joe
biden
and he feels really supported and
emboldened by that and
again giddy keep in mind that when these
people
are regardless of their intention when
they
are storming the capital and going
through those barricades they're
committing
a crime yeah of course he was of course
he was
this really shouldn't be surprising to
anybody
donald trump seemed to at least for some
period of time on january 6th
believe these people might actually
overthrow
the election results overthrow the
government that is set to be sworn in
just two weeks later
and install me as president which would
basically be becoming a dictator right
he would have lost but somehow been
installed by force
this is why he resisted sending in the
national guard
to stop the riots despite being asked to
multiple times and we were
on a live stream many of us were
watching it together wondering okay
it's one o'clock it's two o'clock it's
three o'clock
does it really take this long to muster
national guard i mean we know we have
the biggest military and the best
everything inside it's been two hours
and in a situation where
clearly you need uh uh people to show up
to restore order
nobody's showing up could it really just
be taking this long to get there from
virginia or from maryland or wherever
the case they were stationed
and the answer was of course not of
course not the reason that they didn't
show up
was because donald trump was resisting
sending them and
uh this this confirms everything that
was being reported at the time even if
you looked remember that first
video trump did i'm forgetting the exact
timeline but it might have been five
ish eastern time where trump came out
and said
it's time to go home we love you
paraphrasing here you're justified
in your belief about the election being
stolen the impetus for why you showed up
and rioted
the this is my paraphrasing is a good
one it's an accurate one because it was
really stolen
but as much as we love you it's time to
go home even in that you could tell
trump was thrilled and trump was
was actually supportive of the rioters
and so
that further is corroboration and you
have to read the book to look at the
full the full sourcing of it
um that indeed is more corroboration of
what we already believe to be true
and then lastly we reported a few weeks
ago that
ivanka trump and jared kushner are
supposedly distancing themselves from
donald trump pretty significantly
and carol lennon's additional insights
in the book along with
philip rucker are that ivanka trump was
asking donald trump as the riots were
unfolding
you've got to stop this do something
about this you've got to do something
about it and trump refused and
again if the reporting that we've seen
is to be believed
uh that indeed ivanka trump was not
pleased about that
um that would also uh be um
coherent with what has already been
reported none of this is shocking it's
just none of this we don't there's
nothing that we're hearing here
where we say whoa that's totally out of
character with trump
that just doesn't make any sense no the
impression we got at the time was that
it was because of trump
that authorities didn't show up more
quickly that's exactly the reporting
that has come out since
the our impression at the time from
trump's weird video was
he liked the rioters and that is now
what philip
rucker and carol lennog are uh asserting
in their book i alone can fix it so none
of it is shocking but there is more
detail
in the book um the one other thing i
would say when
sometimes people write to me they say
david like what's the point of this book
now at this point
books take time to write you know to
expect a book about the trump riots
on january 16th 10 days later it's not
it's not reasonable it takes a while to
write books and when you're when you're
writing a book
and sourcing it and fact checking it in
this type of thing it's going to take
some period of time
there were lots of people who weren't
really paying attention back then to
those reports
and they're now hearing this stuff for
the first time and i do think that
that's relevant as well i know trump
owns the republican party
most republicans just don't care about
this or they won't believe it
but i do think that we're exposing more
people to this
reality for the first time and that is
worth it but just an incredible
incredible revelation and completely
coherent with what we believed at the
time
hey um there is this new theme there's
this new talking point that has surfaced
when public figures are asked about
their vaccination status where they say
that's my hipaa that's my hipaa or
that's hipaa um we're going to talk
about the absurdity of this
i've actually mentioned this three or
four times over the last two months
when it would sort of rear it's not ugly
head but very ignorant head
and explain hipaa has nothing to do with
journalists talking to public figures it
just doesn't that you look up the law
look at what hipaa is
but it's now becoming a very common
refrain for people who just don't want
to answer whether they've been
vaccinated so let's look at some
examples here
is radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
she has done anti-vaxx stuff she has
done
compare things to the holocaust stuff
which she then apologized for but then
did it again
this is one of the most radical ignorant
unhinged members of congress
she invoked her hipaa rights
i know i know she was asked are you
vaccinated by a reporter and she said
that's a violation of my hipaa
okay take a look two questions have you
yourself gotten vaccinated and do you
disagree with the republican women
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
you see with hipaa rights we don't have
to reveal our medical records and that
also involves our vaccine records
so she clearly doesn't understand or is
pretending not to understand what hipaa
is
here's another example dallas cowboys
quarterback dak prescott
asked are you vaccinated um and he said
that that's hipaa
hold on hold on is being asked that
hipaa or is answering it
what does it mean that's hipaa it makes
no sense but let's take a look at the
video
have you got the vaccines um i don't
necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clarence i think that's hipaa
but i understand where zeke comes from
um i understand everybody's opinion
um and i think everybody's uh
has that right my hipaa hippa this
hippa that um i would even go further
guys i think being asked about
vaccination
violates the nuremberg codes it violates
the geneva convention it violates
everything
penal code i mean there's this throw
throw any
misused legal term out it violates all
of it and the funniest like little
detail
is 90 of the time they're misspelling
hipaa if you look through our youtube
channel comments
which i don't encourage you to do on on
you know on an empty stomach if you're
planning to eat soon because it's going
to really spoil your appetite
90 of the time the people talking about
hipaa in the context of being asked
about vaccinations spell it like hippo
uh but with an a it's hipaa h-i-p-a-a
it stands for health insurance
portability and accountability act
now to be really crystal clear
hipaa relates only to the storage
and the transmission of your medical
records
by medical providers and by insurance
companies
when you ask someone about their covet
vaccine status
it's not it's not even to say to say
it's a hipaa violation
it has nothing to do with hipaa and
especially when a journalist asks a
public figure are you vaccinated
it has nothing to do with hipaa hipaa
was signed into law by bill clinton in
1996
what was happening in 96 medical records
were in the process of being
computerized
and what hipaa did hipaa doesn't block
anyone from asking questions about
health status
what it does is prohibit certain health
care entities
from revealing your health information
that's all it does
and it shouldn't surprise us in a sense
so
i tweeted over the weekend initially i
tweeted over the weekend
the stupidity of claiming hipaa
violations
when journalists ask public figures
about their vaccination status
is actually even taking me by surprise
but then i thought about it a little
more
and i realized what i tweeted out the
next day
it's not surprising that the same people
who think twitter is violating their
first amendment rights
think that a journalist is violating
hipaa
don't let them get away with this and i
think that there's there's
basically two things that should be done
when these people try to
assert their hipaa rights which is it's
crazy uh it's sort of like
i'm asserting i'm asserting the laws of
gravity
really well what does it mean to assert
them you're bound by them regardless
it just makes no sense okay i think that
there's two things that should be said
one is what is hipaa explain what hipaa
does
and how it relates to the question you
were asked it has to be done
and it's going to be like when people
say that's socialism and we say
what is socialism anyway they don't know
okay ask
what is hipaa but then more importantly
once you've established that they don't
even know
uh go further and say hey regardless of
whether this
is hipaa why is it you don't want to
reveal your vaccination status because
that i'm not hearing that question being
asked and that's really the key question
that's not a trivial thing
whether or not someone can be forced to
reveal their vaccination status
or whether a question violates hipaa
none of it makes any sense
at a certain point when it's a public
figure the next question should be
okay listen let's not debate hipaa what
i want to know is
why are you so interested in keeping
secret your vaccination status is it
because you're worried
that the people that have heard you do
the anti-vac stuff and love you for it
and donate to you for it
are all of a sudden going to abandon you
if they realize actually you've been
vaccinated
uh is it because you've not been
vaccinated and you want to hide that
my instinct is for the most part
the people who don't want to acknowledge
their vaccination status publicly
are right wingers who have toyed with
anti-vaxx
so my instinct is they've probably
mostly been vaccinated
and think it would be damaging to the
brand or would appear hypocritical
to admit that they've received a
vaccination that's my instinct
i'd love to hear from you about it we
have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime you want to chat with me
that voicemail number is 219 to david p
here's a question about a sports related
political story that took place over the
weekend
hey david i was just wondering what your
thoughts are about the cleveland indians
being forced to change their name
um basically just because of a
minority falsely claiming racism i mean
this is a team
whose name has been established for over
a century
and i can't believe i'm saying this i
feel dirty saying this but i
really agree with what donald trump said
a while back
this this really should not have
happened um i'd love to hear your
thoughts about it
so listen here here's the deal all right
um
it is a very bad argument to say that
because a team
has had a certain name for a long time
it's wrong to change it society changes
culture changes and there were lots of
things that we did
it's actually it's sort of the
fundamental
pillar of conservatism keep doing things
a certain way
because we've been doing them a certain
way terrible argument
it's a completely logically fallacious
argument here's my thought about the
cleveland indians changing their name to
the cleveland guardians
i don't really care i don't think it's a
big deal these are decisions that are
made
in a marketplace of ideas the team has
decided they're going to go with
cleveland guardians because
indians is considered you know i don't
know that we have to use the term racist
but just the the
reference to indians in this way
combined with the logo
of the team um hearkens back to
pejorative and xenophobic uses of the
term i guess i would say that that's
sort of undeniable
whether the history and tradition
overrides the need to change it it's not
my call to make
the people now will decide do they no
longer want to support the cleveland
guardians because they don't like the
name
does it reek of woke culture to them
such that they will protest by no longer
going to visit the cleveland guardians
there's one really funny thing about
this though
when donald trump started space force
and they announced near the end of his
presidency
you've got you know marines soldiers all
this different stuff
the space force um members are going to
be
guardians everybody on the right was
cheering it
and doing a standing ovation this is so
patriotic
these are the guardians etc
and now many of the same people are
saying guardians is lame for a baseball
team
explain to me how if guardians is
suitable
for actual members of a branch of the
armed forces
who actually are potentially someday
going to be in positions of having to
defend us with weapons and all this
stuff
it's it's alpha enough for the for them
but not for a baseball team that at the
end of the day is you know
swinging bats and hitting balls that
it's not it's it's beta
in that it's just incre these people are
pathetic these people are pathetic so i
find myself
mostly not caring about it whether it's
a mistake
from the standpoint of business for the
cleveland guardians to do this
we will see in the future all right and
quite frankly i don't care that much one
way or the other about this there's just
such
uh such bigger issues um i want to tell
you that on today's bonus show
we are going to talk about the new
coveted requirements in france and spain
i will soon be in one of those countries
am i pleased or disgusted at what i will
have to do
i will tell you on the bonus show and
much much
more get instant access to today's bonus
show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news
is combating divisiveness in media
ground is a news comparison platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman